Hi, this is Dr. Cutters. Welcome to the video that I'm putting together on the three phases of line.
You are going to download the book. So in this download, I actually separated the book, the book picture there on your left hand side, into four sections.
This book is probably not going to be imprinted. So this is the only way that you're going to get this book.
The four sections go over explicitly by protocols. What are the three phases of line? And what would you do about them?
Now understand, in this book, I've created these protocols. We sell these protocols to our patients. However, if a person is a patient or a clinic, we get a little bit more specific.
But we know that not everybody can be a patient or a clinic, and that's why we put this all together. So I just wanted to let everybody know what I do in my office so that they could get help by never coming to us.
Because I just know that what of the purposes God put me here for is to help people. And if I limit it to only the people that could come to my office that I really am not fulfilling that purpose to the best of my ability.
So that's what this book is about. It's going to go over what are the three phases of line. And if you have line most commonly, most people think that there's only two phases.
So that's going to be described in detail in this book. I also described it in my first book on live. And it's also in detail on my next book in live. That's actually coming out next week.
So by the time you're watching this presentation, it's already out. So you could download that too. That's called line brain.
So that goes over if you have a lot of emotional and neurological issues with your live problems, then make sure you download that book as well. These are all free download. So it's anything to help people that's what we're about.
So when we talk about line in the three phases, the problem with line is always that line is difficult to kill. It hides.
It could meld with a DNA of commensual bacteria in your body and microbes in the body. It could take on a layer on its outside membrane and hide from it immuter response.
It gets into the cells intercellular and hides there. So it's very difficult for your immune system to kill. And that's the problem with line.
Ultimately, it adds up going through these stages that we're going to talk about. And that final stage of live disease is that autoimmune stage. That's that third stage.
So a few people understand live stages. Even live literate medical doctors that are out there typically are treated with high dose antibiotics. And you know what that's going to do to your gut to the rest of your body over a long period of time. It's pretty tough on it.
So fewer people out there, even natural doctors, have a difficult time understanding how to treat an autoimmune disorder.
We don't want to just support it. We still want to be able to kill the live and there's a way to do it. So I go over that in this book.
These three phases of live as you're going to hear over and over in this book are the acute phase. That phase one is the acute phase.
This is the one I recommend you get antibiotics for. So I had live twice by daughter had chronic live. She is in phase two and we managed it in phase two.
Most of my patients are in phase three. So I developed this out of just necessity. I was sick by self by patients who were sick and I believe anytime God said to somebody we're going to figure out how to get them better.
Phase one is acute live. You should treat it with antibiotics. Phase two is chronic live. It's not yet autoimmune.
But the bacteria has gone intracellularly or it's adequately hiding from an immune response. These are the people that are very, very sick.
But they're not yet in the autoimmune phase. You can still treat phase two live with my protocol water, protocol two. And that's with an herbal formulation.
So I have put together an herbal protocol, actually two of them, protocol one, protocol two. You'll read all about it. And that can still be treated phase one, phase two.
Phase three is totally different animal. That's when you now have antibodies to your old self cells.
Once your body has made antibodies to your old cells, now you can't use urmels because every time you strengthen immune response or stimulate immune response, you're going to kill that which you have antibodies against first.
And if you have antibodies against your neural tissue against your brain cells and you spark an immune function or you stimulate an immune function, you are going to kill that which you have antibodies against.
That is your old brain cells. So you can't do that. That's what makes it very difficult and that's why these people are so sick.
They are running around doing protocols that stimulate immune response. That seems logical because I want to kill the live.
But you're helping your body kill itself. So I explained that you got to do it differently when you're in phase three.
So by protocols three and four, our four, this phase. Again, you'll read all about it. In the book, we have links to our website. This is one page on our website where it talks about acute chronic and autoimmune phase.
And even here, a circle that says what phase are you in. There's a way for you to click on it and you could go and even take a quiz and find out what phase you're in. I understand.
This is the biggest comment that we get when we get calls from people with chronic life. They say, I'm destitute, financially destitute. I've been working on this, trying to treat this for 10 years.
I've lost my family, lost my job. I don't have anybody. So we're trying to make this as economical as possible for people. There's lab tests that you could run. I explained it in the book.
We have tests in our office that you could run. I explain that in the book. You're going to learn all about this. The book is free. So be thankful here. And then you can go on the website and take a phase quiz for free.
And learn about what phase you're in and then follow different protocols. Or even if you don't purchase our protocol, you can see in the book, I list everything that's in there.
So you can follow it yourself. I'm trying to make this as valuable to you as possible to reach the masses as much as possible and as cost effective as possible.
Because I bet in your shoes, I know what it's like. So on the website, you're going to see different pages. This is one of the Dr. Cutters Clearline protocols.
Out here, we'll list out all the protocols. Why we do this? What are purposes? All these will be links in the book. You can go to our website there up in the corner and you can see them.
No, but don't get ahead of yourself. Read the book. So you'll get these sections. I broke the whole book out into four sections. You're going to get these four sections over the course of the next couple of weeks.
So every four days, you're going to get another section. So make sure you check your spam folder because it's going up to a lot of people. So go in your spam.
Check your spam folder. Click on the book when you open up the email and you'll open up the whole PDF of that section and you can scroll through it.
Go to the links, check out different things, learn. That's all I care about. I want you to be a better person because of it.
Alright, I hope you enjoy it. That's what the cover of the book looks like. Enjoy it. I hope it's a blessing to many, many people. Bye-bye.